we do acknowledge
that poland is taking on a significant
responsibility
that i don't think should just be poland
it should be the whole world all of
nato's responsibility
the fact that you have
so many so many ukrainians seeking
refuge in in this in this country of
poland
we understand that because we have
in our southern border
thousands of people a day
literally not figuratively
trying to get into the united states but
we believe that we the united states
should do our part relative to
ukraine as well by opening our borders
to another 100 000
people
the united states and
my colleagues
on this side of the table
have heard me say it many many times
we take article five
as a sacred commitment
not a throwaway a sacred commitment
that relates to every member of nato
one of the things that i
thanked
the president for
downstairs was the fact that
the single most
important criteria in this time of the
changing world so much is changing not
just here but in other parts of the
world
is that
nato stay absolutely completely
thoroughly
[Music]
foreign